clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic merci à toi mars 2020 ça fait
officiellement plus de trois ans
maintenant que j'essaie de me faire
retirer ce tatouage que tout le monde
connaît 2 et mon fessier
il s'en est passé des choses en trois
ans pour vous aussi d'ailleurs vous vous
arrêtez pas mal à m'en parler
on y reviendra peut-être tout à l'heure
la dernière fois je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez
j'avais émis l'hypothèse que peut-être
c'était ma dernière séance
et finalement on s'était pas le cas et
mais peut-être que c'est aujourd'hui la
dernière séance je n'en sais rien au
moment où je vous parle puisque je n'y
suis pas encore allé donc ce que je vous
propose comme d'habitude c'est on y va
vous me regardez souffrir et puis je
reviens et ont débriefé un petit peu et
on discute et on voit où on en est
[Musique]
cette vidéo a été tournée avant le
confinement et les restrictions de
déplacements liés à la lutte contre la
propagation du kof 19 donc reste bien
tranquille tu vas faire quoi
c'est complètement n'importe quoi il
fait extrêmement beau comme vous pouvez
le voir
par contre là il rêve
on ne va pas vraiment
c'est très prometteur
[Musique]
ah oui c'est lui oui
ok donc il s'est passé des choses et
plein de trucs à vous raconter vous avez
deviné r parce que vous avez vu le titre
de la vidéo avant de plonger dans le
coeur du sujet dans le vif vous avez été
pas mal à me raconter ce qui vous était
arrivé à vous pendant les trois ans qu'a
duré cette expérience j'ai trouvé ça
assez marrant donc voilà ce qui s'est
passé pour vous alors suivant les cas
vous avez passé votre bac vous avez
commencé vos études et fini vos études
en acompte trouver du boulot changer de
boulot plusieurs fois monter leur boîte
you may qui ont perdu leur pucelage il y
en a qui ont rencontré l'amour y en a
qu'on vécu à des ruptures ans ça arrive
aussi y en a qui ont eu des bébés vous
avez vu star wars 7 8 9
vous vous êtes fait tatouer vous avez
appris des langues étrangères vous vous
êtes fâché avec vos parents etc
je trouve ça vraiment marrant comme
comme petit jeu et j'ai eu envie de
jouer aussi
donc du coup alors qu'est ce qui s'est
passé pendant ces un peu plus de trois
ans parce qu'on voudrait le tatouage ça
a commencé mais mon petit peu avant mais
alors pendant ces trois ans
donc là une rupture et là je me suis pas
fâché avec mes parents mais par contre
même mère est morte ma grand-mère est
morte j'ai eu un procès
des embrouilles familiale d'une rupture
[Musique]
yes bon alors on va prendre les choses
autrement
pendant ces trois ans je suis tombé
amoureux 1
j'ai une nature mais je suis tombé
amoureux ça c'est ça c'est bien j'ai
rencontré plein de gens hyper cool hyper
cool j'ai eu un procès mais j'ai gagné
mon procès des ombres familial mais j'ai
fait du tri donc du coup ça c'est plutôt
pas mal
j'ai vu un nombre incalculable de
concerts j'ai découvert des groupes
hyper cool je suis allé à plein de
festivals c'était vraiment vraiment top
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait d'autres j'ai
voyagé
c'est vachement dur sata 2 de voyager
j'ai découvert ont re découvert des pays
je suis allé dans des endroits dans
lesquels j'avais envie d'aller depuis
depuis des années donc vraiment il s'est
passé aussi plein de trucs très très
cool pendant c'est pendant ces trois ans
et à chaque fois
cyril était là qui m'accompagnait non au
creux de mon au creux de mon clip
alors il m'a accompagné de de moins en
moins évidemment et puis maintenant
et puis maintenant et puis maintenant il
va falloir
il va falloir couper le cordon il va
falloir apprendre à vivre sans cyril
parce que voilà vous l'avez compris
c'est entre syrie et moi c'est terminé
by taj bada c'est la france et là que
nos chemins se séparent enfin je je je
vais vous expliquer donc oui il reste
des petites traces on en a déjà parlé
dans la vidéo la dernière fois faut pas
oublier que la depuis j'ai refait un
coup de laser donc dans les semaines qui
viennent ça va encore continuer à
s'estomper
et puis j'ai discuté avec le médecin le
médecin m'a dit que j'étais clairement
son pire patients en termes de nombre de
séances et pour vous montrer qu'on n'est
pas tous égaux devant le laser je vous
mets la photo qui m'a montré de son
meilleur patients en termes de nombre de
séances voilà là là c'est après une
seule séance
donc voilà on n'est pas tous égaux là il
m'a dit qu'on a son sens on n'aurait pas
beaucoup mieux que ça et il m'a donné un
programme pour la suite
au programme vous allez voir assez
original
j'espère je peux encore prévue
oui
c'est pas sûr mais s'il le faut je suis
prêt à tours un peu de bronzage là
dessus si c'est si c'est une
prescription médicale moi vous savez je
suis impatient
[Musique]
très bien c'est remboursé par la sécu ça
je rends pas compte
pour résumer on arrête les séances et
puis bah je laisse le temps à mon
organisme dé la tuer les dernières
traces de pigments par rapport à cette
dernière séance de laser notamment et
puis cet été
et bah je dois bronze et les fesses
voilà l'idée c'est que je vais me
protéger attention je vais pas faire
n'importe quoi mais l'idée c'est que le
soleil et le bronzage ça fasse un peu
son job sur tout ce qui est des
pigmentations ça atténue les ombres etc
donc je fais ça je bronze des fesses
j'attends un petit peu que tout ça des
bronzes et un petit peu après la rentrée
prochaine
genre fin septembre début octobre je
retourne voir le médecin et m'a offert
un petit vélo donc c'est fini
oui c'est fini pour le moment peut-être
peut-être dur à une toute dernière
séance à la rentrée peut-être qu'il y
aura plus rien du tout je n'en sais rien
en tout cas en attendant moi je me
prépare psychologiquement à faire
d'ultimes ou à porter un string
enfin j'ai pas encore choisi je vous
cache pas que je vais faire ça
évidemment je vous tiendrai au courant
de toute façon je referai une vidéo ne
serait ce que pour répondre à toutes les
questions que vous m'avez posée
et puis pour faire un petit point voilà
de toute cette aventure merveilleuse qui
dure depuis maintenant plus de plus de 3
en un petit point un comptable un petit
point
ce que ça a changé dans ma vie tout ça
on fera un petit on fera un petit point
on en reparlera mais la papa tout de
suite tout de suite là on va laisser on
va laisser les fesses faire de la blague
on va laisser les choses se faire on en
reparle en c4 mais en attendant
évidemment rester sur les tc vous ne
verrez plus mes fesses aussi souvent
mais on se retrouve la très très bientôt
genre la semaine prochaine pour d'autres
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous
prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout restez chez
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]